[Musik]
robert ratlos der auftritt von
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck bewegt
deutschland und auch uns hier heute
abend bei für den a8 meine gäste heute
abend sind linke politikerin und
bundestagsabgeordnete sahra wagenknecht
wenige politiker sind in diesem land so
bekannt und beliebt gesehen schön dass
sie da so frau wagenknecht für den tick
wissenschaftler und publizist dennison
er sagt wir dürfen uns von putin nicht
erpressen lasse leiter der bild
parlamentsredaktion und filme acht
stammgast ralf schuler sein thema heute
abend kein klamauk mit katar
spd-politikerin und bürgermeisterin ein
opern sie fordert politik muss wieder
nah sein ich würde ja sagen die politik
sollte vor allem keine lehrlinge mehr in
hohen ämtern beschäftigen aber schauen
wir doch mal rein welchen hier sinn
robert habe gestern abend in der sendung
von sandra maischberger erzählt hat dass
liegen wir jetzt überall das leben die
darauf angewiesen sind dass die menschen
geld ausgeben blumenläden bioläden
leckereien gehören dazu dass die
wirkliche probleme haben weil ist eine
kaufzurückhaltung gibt und dann sind die
nicht insolvent automatisch aber sie
hören vielleicht auch zu verkaufen und
dass ich aufhöre zu verkaufen verdiene
ich kein geld mehr da muss ich die
insolvenz anmelden nach zwei monaten
wenn dies nicht getan habe habe ich in
st.wendel man würde man würde dann
insolvent werden wenn man mit der arbeit
immer größeres minus macht ja aber wie
willst du denn kein größeres minus
machen wenn sie leute bezahlen aber dies
wir verkaufen also wie soll man also ich
hab es nicht verstehe ich weiß auch dass
ich automatisch eine insolvenzwelle
geben begeben muss aber es kann sein
dass ich bestimmte geschäfte nicht mehr
rentieren und die dann eingestellt
werden vielleicht werden sie später
wieder aufgenommen das kann ja sein also
das ist dann ja keine klassische
insolvenz aber es kann sein wenn wir
keine abhilfe schaffen dass die
betriebe dakar ein handwerksbetriebe
reinigungsfirmen und so weiter über
dieses jahr dann die wirtschaftliche
betätigung einstellen das ist eine
gefahr und der müssen wir begegnen frau
wagenknecht so erklärt robert habeck
eine insolvenz beziehungsweise eine
nicht insolvenz man merkt auf jeden fall
braucht nachhilfe vertrauen sie diese
minister dennoch also ich meine den
kammern ja nicht von rauen ich muss
sagen als ich das gesehen habe ich war
einfach fassungslos
also ich mir haben wir befinden uns in
einer dramatischen situation
deutschland steuert wegen dieser
explodierenden energiepreise auf eine
wirtschaftliche und soziale katastrophe
zu und wir haben im
wirtschaftsministerium jemanden sitzen
der offenbar elementare wirtschaftliche
zusammenhänge nicht kennt oder nicht
durchschaut oder nicht durchschauen will
und ich meinte ok man kann ja mal einen
ausfall haben man kann mal einen abend
schlecht drauf sein also das könnte man
ja noch hinnehmen aber ehrlich sagt das
ist ja nicht der erste ausfall ich mein
während andere länder zum beispiel
energiepreise deckeln in frankreich
steigt steigt der strompreis in diesem
jahr um vier prozent im ganzen jahr der
sprit diesel und benzin sind um 40 cent
pro liter billiger als hier und während
also hier alles weiter nach oben geht
hat unser toller wirtschaftsminister die
idee das mache ich noch mal bisschen was
obendrauf mache gas umlage und lässt
auch noch die energie lobbyisten diese
gasanlage also das gesetz dafür
schreiben und wundert sich dann dass es
genauso aussieht wie es aussieht wenn
hobbyisten von unternehmen sich ein
gesetz basteln nämlich ein
selbstbedienungsladen also insoweit das
ist ja eine folge von ausfällen und ich
sag mal wenn nur ein minister schlecht
drauf wäre in dieser ampel obwohl das
ist ja ein schlüssel ressort aber auch
das wäre schon schlimm genug aber es ist
ja die ganze regierung ich meine die
haben den ernst der lage nicht erkannt
sie haben uns jetzt nochmal da ein neues
entlastungspaket offeriert klopfen sich
auf die schulter wie viel sie da jetzt
machen natürlich sind da auch sinnvolle
dinge drin also was will ich in abrede
stellen also nachdem man die rentner und
die studenten vergessen hatte ist es
natürlich gut dass die jetzt auch
einmalzahlung bekommen und es ist sicher
auch gut dass wohngeldempfänger jetzt
einen heizkostenzuschuss bekommen wobei
man eben auch wissen muss
98,5 prozent der deutschen bevölkerung
sind keine wohngeldempfänger und auch
bei denen explodieren die heizkosten und
was noch viel schlimmer ist und das ist
ja wieder das thema auch was hab ich ja
so versucht kleinzureden die
insolvenzwelle hat ja schon begonnen die
insolvenzen steigen und das obwohl die
richtige kostenlawine viele unternehmen
erst im nächsten jahr treffen wird weil
sie langfristige verträge haben für
energielieferungen wir haben einen
deutlichen
produktionseinbruch also es wird ja
immer so gesagt oder die industrie
verbraucht wird sich 20 prozent weniger
als da sagt in der regierung teilweise
noch eine gute leistung ja woran liegt
denn das das liegt daran dass die
produktion dramatisch zurückgeht
aluminiumhütten porzellanhersteller
papierindustrie in so vielen bereichen
sind inzwischen schon werden produktion
eingestellt wir haben verlagerungen
beispielsweise in die usa weil der
gaspreis in deutschland seit acht mal so
hoch ist wie in den usa da kündigen
viele an ja wir gehen dahin und deswegen
finde ich einfach wir müssen doch über
die wirklichen ursachen mal reden wir
können es uns in deutschland nicht
leisten dass unsere energie immer teurer
wird wir brauchen preiswerte energie und
wir können die aktuell das gefällt mir
auch nicht ich finde das nicht schön
aber wir können sie aktuell nur in
russland beziehen und deswegen muss man
ganz klar sagen schluss mit diesen
fatalen wirtschaftssanktionen die
schaden uns gazprom macht rekordgewinne
wir haben dieses jahr schon im ersten
halbjahr mehr verdient als im ganzen
jahr zuvor also wie kann man den glauben
dass wir damit putin bestrafen wir
bestrafen uns wir stürzen die menschen
in armut wird zerstören unsere industrie
und ich finde das darf man so nicht
weitermachen
und das muss doch eigentlich ist aufgabe
der ampel verhandeln sie über eine
wiederaufnahme der gaslieferungen heben
sie die sanktionen auf weil sonst
zerstören wir wirklich deutschland und
in der rille das kann man nicht die
deutsche wirtschaft aber eben auch den
wohlstand der menschen und das ist
inakzeptabel hätten würden sie mitgehen
ich finde es ist ungeheuer wichtig dass
deutschland es sich besser schützen kann
auch in dem es nicht abhängig ist vom
russischen gas jetzt es stimmt auch dass
deutschland weiter russischen gas chaos
bis 91 jetzt geschlossen worden ist weil
wir wissen ja alle dass so eine schnelle
veränderung auf andere energiequellen
unheimliche nicht nur wirtschaftlich
sondern sozialen kosten hat nicht
möglich ist
also ich bin zuversichtlich aus manchen
dass ein markt ziemlich schnell
reagieren
aber man muss auch bereit sein zu sagen
jetzt ist opfer verlag denn man hat so
lange fehlern gemacht wenn man den
atommeilern ausschalten will okay aber
dann muss man ein alternativ haben
sodass man krisen aus baden kann
länger in deutschland nicht anzapfen wir
die economy sagte wenn deutschland hier
schiefergas
anzapfen würde könnte es ein
gasproduktion in zwölf bis 18 monate
verdoppeln und 15 milliarden euro
bleiben mit deutschland start nach
russland zu geben in dem sinne wir sehen
viele stellen wo nicht langfristig
gedacht worden ist und jetzt muss man
das ausbaden wenn man brüssel und
wirtschaftssanktionen aber ich bin für
die wirtschaftssanktionen war so viel
auf dem spiel steht ich will keinen
atomkrieg mit russland ich will
deutschlands wirtschaft auch nicht
ruiniert denn ich weiß wenn die
wirtschaft kaputt ist wie deutschland
sowieso nicht gegen russland aber ich
weiß auch
wenn putin der meinung ist dass
militärische operation gegen andere
länder in politische vorteile bringen
david bringen die wirtschaftssanktionen
bislang also was wäre die wirtschaft
sorgen zum beispiel
natürlich das volk kann nicht sofort
aufstehen und sagen wir wollen diesen
krieg nicht mehr landen die allem knast
aber zb die militärische fähigkeiten
russland sind dramatisch gefallen war
sie importe nicht bekommt russland kauft
at wie geschosse von nordkorea das haben
die wirtschaftssanktionen gemacht
langfristig ist es auch so dass diese
fehlende gelder zugang zu westlichen
märkten
den größten schaden wird aber
nur wegen wirtschaftsprobleme beenden
das glaube ich nicht aber die gute alte
denon hat gesagt die kapitalisten die
werden uns dem saal verkaufen mit denen
wir die aufhängen und ich fürchte wir
haben zulagen die russen das geld
gegeben so dass sie andere länder
angreifen können und es gibt keinen
frieden in europa solange putin und
seine armee in ukraine militärisch nicht
einer meinung aber haben sie dennoch ein
fakt wo sie sagen da sieht man wirklich
das helfe da helfen die
wirtschaftssanktionen und
da sind detaillierte studie nämlich
gemacht und man hat ziemlich heber kraft
russland ist sehr von hightech abhängig
nicht nur in der waffenindustrie aber
die präzision waffen die die nicht mehr
haben die kunden nicht nach produziert
auch in der energie forderung geht
manches kaputt es ist schwierig für die
russen alle pumpen am laufen zu halten
die brauchen diese westliche technologie
jetzt langfristig vielleicht kann ich
china da reinkommen aber erst mal sind
die pipelines nach westen gerichte und
wenn diese geldquelle nicht mehr da sind
und die technologie nicht mehr da sind
dann werden die russen wenn es sich geld
übrig haben um ihre kriege zu
finanzieren
vielleicht ich meinen militärisch muss
man denn auch vor harten fakten stellen
ich glaube dass sanktionen allein nicht
reichen aber mal soll die trotzdem nicht
ausgegeben machen einmal die runde
weiter frau kann wenn sie die ganzen
probleme jetzt aber an trauen sie es
denn wirtschaftsminister harbeck zu dass
er richtig entscheidet sanktion
notwendig oder nicht und den kurs für
deutschland kennt also grundsätzlich
traue ich das schon dem
wirtschaftsminister habe so natürliches
gestern wieder ein beispiel was gerade
nicht gut läuft und ich merke dass als
bürgermeisterin auch sehr stark dass die
leute bei mir in der sprechende sitzen
und sagen was machen die da also die
reden auch schon von die da oben und das
finde ich ja auch schon sehr fatal wenn
man sich schon so in zwei schichten
sieht und gar nicht als 1 sieht so und
wir hatten jetzt das thema gas umlage
was leider
kommunikativ nicht sehr gut warum nicht
sehr stark weil es hatten wir gestern
wieder am beispiel das ist nicht das was
wir uns da ich meine basis wünschen also
wir wünschen uns klare direkte
kommunikation ist auch das was sich die
menschen vor ort wünschen die kommen
damit klar wenn man den sagt das geht
oder das geht nicht aber es muss klar
direkt und schnell sein und nicht in
einer blase umwelt sein ich hab mal eine
grafik vorbereitet jetzt bild gefragt
also wir haben ja gesagt die da oben und
die bürger also wer traut ist denn
robert habeck eigentlich noch zu und da
sehen wir ja also das nur 7 prozent
glauben dass haarweg uns durch die krise
bringt stand 17 35 93 glauben es nicht
es waren jetzt auch gar nicht so wenig
teilnehmer sahen 290.000 dementsprechend
die frage jetzt an ralf schuler wie kann
es denn sein nehmen wir noch mal den
auftritt von frau maischberger gestern
arbeiten denn im wirtschaftsministerium
keine fähigen leute die ihn briefen
können und vielleicht auch vor diesem
jahr debakel bewahren können dass wir
jetzt schon wieder sehr beim eingemachte
das
wirtschaftsministerium ist in einem
ständigen das ist traditionell so
machtkampf mit dem finanzministerium
oskar lafontaine damals als
finanzminister wurde hat als erstes dem
wirtschaftsministerium die
grundsatzabteilung weggenommen weil da
die experten darin saßen seitdem ist die
meines wissens bei finanzministerium
geblieben
da ist im augenblick jetzt das
wirtschaftsministerium in einer sehr
schlechten verfassung da ist wenig
wirtschaftskompetenz dafür hat robert
habeck als 1 amt kam sehr viele
klimaaktivisten und lobbyisten direkt
reinhold patrick reichen vorher agora
energiewende ein lupenreiner lobbyist
der frühere grünen geschäftsführer
keller ist da jetzt staatssekretär
die haben alle mit wirtschaften nur ein
mittelbares verhältnis weil man dachte
man muss das klima retten und nicht sich
um die wirtschaft kümmern die ist ja da
und brummte das arbeit meine das
wirtschaftsministerium ist jetzt auch
nicht die schülerhilfe für robbi tobbi
und das fliewatüüt das noch mal eben
auch ganz klar mal sagen denn jemanden
wirtschaftsminister ist insolvenz kann
man wissen das ist jetzt wirklich nicht
das ganze die ganz hohe kunst das
problem ist aber dass diese dieser
lapsus von
nicht berbalk das ist die andere von
erlaubt kennen robert habe
symptomatisch ist denn frau habe frau
roth hat schon angesprochen diese gas
umlage ist ein massives politikversagen
einer der größten fehler das merkt man
nicht so richtig weil es ja technisch
daherkommt weil denen sich diese ampel
der zeit geleistet hat man hat einfach
uniqa mit uniqa besprochen haben gesagt
wir brauchen mehr geld wir können uns
aber nicht an unsere anteilseigner ist
würde diese eine finnische konzern kann
man es nicht wenden weil naja das ist
immer schwierig einen anteilseigner hat
ein hohes interesse dass seine firma
bleibt und dass nicht so viel geld
verliert die stecken da schon geld rein
und wenn man dann hilft dann kauft man
gefälligst anteile und hat dann kann
dann mitreden
1 gegen lobbying fund und nicht 34
milliarden von den menschen draußen ein
um eine firma zu retten das wäre
billiger gegangen und es wäre auch nicht
zu solchen fehlleistungen gekommen dass
jetzt firmen dies überhaupt nicht
brauchen geld kriegen das ist völlig
irre und es ist ein zeichen dafür dass
sie nicht dass sie es nicht können das
ist einfach man hätte irgendein
wirtschaftsfachmann der sich mit
unternehmensrecht auskennt dazu holen
müssen dann hätte dann lösen wir das
problem nein das funktioniert nicht und
das ist leider eben eine fehlleistung
die beim kopf des ministeriums anfängt
und bis in die tiefen mit hinein geht
das ist auf die dauer wir das nicht
hinkriegen wenn jemand dort sitzt der
die anrollende pleitewelle mit einer art
betriebsferien verwechselt dann gute
nacht deutschland frau wagen sich gerade
kam es auch schon auf frau berbalk zu
sprechen kann man denn überhaupt sich
vorstellen dass mit ihr als
außenministerin jemals die
wirtschaftssanktionen zurückgenommen
oder überhaupt überlegt wird sie
zurückzunehmen na ja gut das entscheidet
nicht die außenministerin am ende muss
es eigentlich in der gesamten regierung
entschieden werden und die frage ist ja
also das verstehe ich nicht man muss
doch mal eine bilanz ziehen also man hat
gesagt wir machen jetzt
wirtschaftssanktionen und putin unter
druck zu setzen ok also ich meine ich
will auch dass dieser furchtbare krieg
aufhört und ich finde das auch
verbrecherisch wobei schon ein bisschen
fragwürdig finde auf andere kriege haben
wir nicht so reagiert mit sanktionen
also wenn saudi arabien irgendwo krieg
führt wenn der türkei oder gar die usa
gab es nie sein sohn aber egal also man
hat gesagt wir wollen jetzt putin unter
druck setzen so da muss man doch nach
mehreren monaten mal gucken wer setzt
jetzt eigentlich wegen unter druck ist
putin unter druck also dass sie jetzt
militärgüter brauchen ja klar weil die
führen jetzt krieg seit mehreren monaten
und so viel können die gar nicht
produzieren natürlich kaufen jetzt
weltweit ein aber am ende gucke ich mir
einfach an wie steht der rubel wie
stehen die russischen einnahmen die die
prosperieren sie hat mir vor allem ja
auch erreicht der größte teil der welt
beteiligt sich nicht das öl ich meine
warum ist der ölpreis nicht so gestiegen
wie der gaspreis deshalb weil sie das öl
relativ leicht umlenken konnten also
jetzt kaufen eben china und indien alle
kaufen das öl teilweise kaufen wir ist
sogar wieder indirekt weil
definiert also rafft macht raffinerien
mit russischem öl und verkauft uns dann
den diesel total brillante idee und weil
das so toll ist machen wir jetzt ende
des jahres das haben wir hat ja aber
auch entschieden klemmen wir jetzt noch
die letzte pipeline ab wo wir aus
russland öl bekommen dann raffiniert
nicht mehr schwedt sondern nur noch
indien und wir kaufen den diesel dann
dort zum fünffachen preis also völlig
verrückt und man muss doch jetzt einfach
sehen bei uns ist ein unglaublicher
schaden wir überleben es wirtschaftlich
nicht die deutsche industrie der
wichtigste standort vorteil den wir
hatten war billige energie deswegen ist
deutschland nicht so deindustrialisiert
wie andere länder ich meine man kann
sich in nordengland angucken wie das
aussieht wenn die industrialisierung
stattfindet oder im raesfeld in den usa
das kennen sie wahrscheinlich besser als
ich dass sie dramatisch
energie ist billig geworden in den usa
ist ja das ist ja auch interessant
lassen
jetzt ist es ja so es leiden ja auch
nicht alle gleich unter den sanktionen
ich meine da erwarte ich auch dass die
deutsche regierung mal bilanz zieht was
heißt das für unser land in den usa
bedeutet das eine boomende fracking
gasindustrie die jetzt ja auch
exportieren kann die also mit einem
tanker zurzeit 200 millionen euro gewinn
macht das zahlen dann alles hier die
verbraucher und die unternehmen oder sie
gehen im pleite so das heißt für die usa
ist das gar nicht so ein schlechtes
setting an mehrere radio 8 deutschland
aufgerufen man ziehen und zu sein und
wir leiden und hier gehen die
unternehmen kaputt und ich meine wie
soll deutschland aussehen der
dihk-präsident sagt wir werden
wahrscheinlich 20 bis 30 prozent ärmer
wenn wir das weiter machen 30 prozent
also frauen in deutschland sich so
erpressbar gemacht hat aber es ist auch
verantwortungslos den russen mehr geld
zu geben als absolut notwendig natürlich
langfristig würde ich auch der
nordstream 2 wieder aufmachen aber nur
unter bestimmten bedingungen dass
russland seine truppen auszutreten
staaten raus muss man mit denen
verhandeln ich bin ja
krieg zu beenden mit verhandlungen aber
zunächst mal müssen wir doch gucken
russland hat durch die gestiegenen
preise obwohl sie viel weniger verkaufen
zum beispiel beim gas beim öl gar nicht
mehr verkaufen sie fast genauso viel
haben sie rekordgewinne das heißt
deutschland hat im ersten halbjahr
dieses jahres in der monitor also geld
mehr ist ich mehr aus russland
importiert als vorher
sie sagen es würde länger dauern bis die
sanktionen wirken also der feuer das
halte ich jetzt für eine völlige legende
weil was passiert jetzt gasproben nutzt
die rekordgewinne und baut die pipelines
nach china aus das heißt baut
zusätzliche pipelines nach china
russland orientiert sich jetzt immer
stärker nach china ist ja auch logisch
können sie ja gar nicht anders und beim
öl ist es ohnehin schon so wollen wir
das wollen wir tatsächlich
wir haben das glück dass russland und
china oft mehr miteinander sagen als mit
den anderen nachbarn
der mentale punkt ist will
deutschlandweite diese krieg finanzieren
und
das je weniger geld deutschland nach
russland schickt desto besser jetzt sie
haben auch recht wegen öl breite
heutzutage kann man ziemlich viel noch
einziehen aber nicht von deutschland
erstmal
und wichtiger noch ist dass putin sehr
gut weiß dass er vielleicht deutschland
von dieser geschlossene koalition gegen
seinen angriff gegen sogar einbrechen
kann wenn er den deutschen dazu bringen
kannst du denken alles steht auf dem
spiel und das war sehr schlau von putin
er hat deutschland abhängig gemacht von
einem hammer aber der ist ein bisschen
wie ein geheißen meine deutschen in
geiselhaft aber die koalition ist noch
nicht geschlossen also die türkei
beteiligt sich an keinen sanktionen es
gibt auch betriebsverlagerungen türkei
zum beispiel aus meiner heimat im
saarland ein traditionshersteller
porzellan geht in die türkei weil die
türkei hat zwei pipelines aus russland
lässt sich natürlich
auf dieser koalition ist nicht
geschlossen um gerade diese schwäche
provoziert putin er denkt wir werden
nicht ernst ist gegen ihm ins feld
bringen werde vor allem deutschland noch
mehr macht absolut weil man das ist eine
medikation ihren denn wir werden
natürlich man muss eine strategie haben
wo man weder den dritten weltkrieg noch
bankrott hat aber auf der anderen seite
kann man nicht sagen weil wir uns nicht
ruinieren wollen müssen wir alles zu
lassen was gut ihn macht nein denn wenn
er erfolg hat in der ukraine dann
schaute auch auf dem baltikum denn wenn
man hört was putin sagt er will nicht
mit ukraine aufhören und ich sage wieder
würde deutschland stärke zeigen es würde
putin überraschend
kalkuliert damit dass deutschland immer
auf die bremse drückt statt auf den
gasbedarf wenn es um widerstand gegen
seine pläne geht na gut wenn man am
tropf hängt es ist schwierig stärke zu
zeigen erzählt ich denke manchmal dass
frau wagenknecht dann manchmal so ein
bisschen die kommunistische plattform
doch wieder durchschimmert
ich kann das nur als irgendwie so ein
bisschen zu den latenten freude daran
sehen dass der westen dann da stünde
wenn wir jetzt zu kreuze kriechen
müssten und 92 aufmachen und weil wir ja
wir haben es probiert wir haben versucht
abzuklemmen ja jetzt ist sie jetzt falls
uns ein bisschen lassen was wieder
verstehst du da wieder wieder betrunken
wie du siehst du da wieder
verweichlichte begossene pudel der sich
zu viel vorgenommen hat mit seinem
sanktionen wenn man solche sanktionen
beschließt da kann man vorher darüber
nachdenken ob es einem selbst oder
jemand wenn man sie beschlossen hat kann
man nicht in andere länder ziehen eben
wenn jetzt mehr man merkt er
musste da kann man sagen kommen
als andere länder macht nix da ja gut
also wie gesagt
das andere problem ist doch die deutsche
öffentlichkeit sehen sich ja immer
danach möglichst nicht militärisch zu
agieren weil militär ist immer böse und
dann
folgt die politik dem opportunistisch
wie sie ist und sagt ja sanktionen also
wir liefern zum beispiel kein obst gibt
einen apple a day keeps putin werde
sagte der frühere agrarminister mal in
seinem unnachahmlichen englisch das ist
alles schwachsinn aber es folgt
natürlich einer stimmungslage die sagt
was können wir ihn nicht mit friedlichen
mitteln umlenken muss man sich klar
machen dass man einen koloss wie
russland nicht einfach so
sie dann also dass wir im jahre aber
eingreifen ein aber man kann jetzt nicht
einfach wie sie daherkommen und kann
sagen jetzt zu apa das ist jetzt noch
alles ziemlich hart dann macht man aus
dem 2 auf und nehmen das billige gas und
der sitzt dann in seinem in kremmen und
sagt so habe ich gesagt ich brauche für
sechs monate und schon kommen die zu
kreuze glaube ich die möglichkeit dass
ein maximalpreis er hat aber das große
problem ist doch die energiewende die
energiewende ist der größte und
massivste fehler der ära merkel gewesen
nicht nur von ihr verschuldet sondern
von allen beteiligten erst aus atom
auszusteigen dann aus kohle auszusteigen
und zu glauben die rechnung geht auf und
stattdessen sich einseitig abhängig zu
machen von gas und jetzt hängen wir hier
am tropf der boden geblickt und einmal
nicht in die vergangenheit in die
gegenwart und kommen zu ihrer these weil
sie haben ja eigentlich eine forderung
was deutschland machen müsste als tier
sollte am mitgebracht
da wir jetzt viele zu diskussion und ich
bin amerikaner ja und ich weiß die
sicherheit frieden freiheit wohlstand
deutschlands ist amerika wichtig ich
weiß auch für deutschland ist amerika
wird jetzt hinter einem schicksals
partnerschaft ich liebe dieses land
leben schon lange hier bin aber der
meinung deutschland tut zu wenig um sich
selbst zu schützen
um andere regierungen in der
nachbarschaft zu beeinflussen um die
globalisierung in seinem sinne zu
gestalten weil deutschland ist so groß
und so reich und geostrategische so
wichtig es kann nicht auf einfluss
verzichten es kann auch nicht auf der
konkurrenz mit china und russland
verzichten es hat eine andere rolle als
im kalten krieg jetzt bei der ukraine
ich habe schon gesagt dass deutschland
sollte lieber auf dem gaspedal ein
bisschen drücken statt immer nur auf der
bremse
deutschland ist groß genug dass auch
führen sind von den ersten schritt
nehmen war ein bisschen ja jetzt mit
waffen
die die bundeswehr hat probleme das muss
man auch zugeben und wir haben uns sehr
verwundbar gemacht war deutschland ist
umschlagplatz und alles und dann
gehandelt und man ist er verwundbar aber
die ukraine
können mit deutschen waffen
leben an der ukraine retten und jetzt
sind die russen in zu 20 prozent von der
ukraine wo bis zu zehn millionen leute
gelebt haben und wir wissen was sind
bucher und den mario pohl passiert ist
und je schneller die ukraine die russen
aus dieser gegenden treiben kann desto
besser ist es irgendwann glaube ich mit
oder ohne deutsche waffen aber putin
wird beeindruckt sein wenn die deutschen
waffen liefern denn das sind ja gerade
die pazifisten und wenn die dann in den
schlaf aus rein gehen dann erneut die
angst bekam das cover und angst vor
allem deutschen revanchismus nein aber
angst dass sein plan den westen zu
zersetzen und deutschland immer so
dazwischen zu halten aller rapallo ja da
will der als bekommen das ist nicht auf
frau wagenknecht werden wir schaffen das
putin zu angst erstarrt naja also erst
mal deutschland liefert ja machen also
ist ja nicht so dass wir nichts liefern
also wenn das nicht alles lüge ist was
was die abwägung brüstet sich ja sogar
damit dass sie schwere waffen liefern
die frage ist was was hilft das den
menschen in der ukraine
ich meine dieser krieg läuft jetzt seit
über einem halben jahr und wir sehen die
russen kommen viel langsamer voran als
sie das dachten keine frage aber sie
kommen voran und sie werden
wahrscheinlich aus diesen gebieten
zumindest wenn es nicht auf dem
verhandlungsweg geht militärisch nicht
wieder raus zu kriegen sein dh der
einzige weg dieses sterben zu beenden
ist dass man eine diplomatische
initiative startet und dann wird immer
wieder putin will ja gar nicht
verhandeln ja machen wir doch mal die
probe aufs exempel es wurde auch gesagt
es lohnt nicht über weizen lieferungen
zu verhandeln nur und haben die europäer
auch nichts gemacht man hat es erdogan
dem türkischen präsidenten überlassen
dass der dann die initiative ergriffen
hatten hat ihr seid ihr jetzt ich hol
dir jetzt an einen tisch und die sollen
jetzt mal bitte irgendwie sich
verständigen dass hier wieder weizen
schiffe durch schwarze meer fahren
können und es war erfolgreich
nur dann höre ich meine kann man
erhalten davon was man will gerhard
schröder hat offensichtlich einen draht
zu putin er war dort nichts erreicht
nicht märz einen menschen der communio
erreichen der kann doch nicht der kann
doch keine autorität zu verhandeln er
ist zurückgekommen hatte offenbar von
putin den auftrag hier die botschaft zu
verbreiten putin möchte verhandeln das
hat ja gesagt also schröder kam zurück
und hat gesagt putin möchte verhandeln
er möchte den krieg auf verhandlungsweg
beenden ja das ist doch eine botschaft
da muss man doch anfangen auszuloten
okay natürlich kann man jetzt nicht
sagen also die verhandlungen bedeutet
russland besetzt die ukraine und wir
beenden dadurch den weg aber man muss
doch dann gucken wie kann man mit dem
reden wie kann man eine vereinbarung
finden statt immer nur zu sagen wer
wählen doch gar nicht also wenn man
jetzt schröder ist ein sprachrohr
betrachtet hat er uns vermittelt er
möchte frau kolb an als ich würde ja
schon sagen junge sliden fehlt der spd
in der hunderte abitur die spd denn
genug für verhandlungen jahre ist würde
ich schon sagen dass die spd genug tut
und ich möchte noch mal erinnern dass
bevor der krieg ja losging wie viele
spitzenpolitiker auch olaf scholz waren
dann in russland an diesem langen tisch
wenn man diese bilder gesehen irgendwie
acht meter gefühlt entfernung zwischen
dem spitzenpolitiker und putin und haben
gesprochen es ist ja nicht so dass alle
zugeschaut haben und gesagt haben uns
ist das egal was da vor ort passt wenn
er genug leute da um mit putin zu
sprechen und ich glaube tatsächlich
nicht daran dass putin egal wer da jetzt
hin fährt oder anruft und mit ihm
verhandeln möchte dass er sagt ja dann
machen wir das jetzt so wir hören jetzt
mit dem krieg auf ich ziehe meine panzer
zurück ich glaube da machen sie ein
bisschen zu einfach weil einfach im
vorfeld viel geredet worden ist und das
vergessene vielleicht ein bisschen aber
das ist ja im vorfeld schon einiges
passiert wobei der entscheidende
politiker gerade nicht da war und auch
nicht mit putting geredet hatten das war
joe biden also es ging ja die wirklich
strittige frage seit jahren ist ja die
frage einer möglichen nato
mitgliedschaft das hat russland immer
als ein absolut rote linie betrachtet
und die usa haben trotzdem zunehmend die
ukrainischen streitkräfte in die nato
integriert so und natürlich ist europa
deutschland hat damals das veto
eingelegt das ihn gab es keine formale
mitgliedschaft aber es gab auch nie eine
zusage dass zum beispiel keine
raketenbasen in die ukraine verlegt
werden wie sie in polen und rumänien
gibt und beiden hat es abgelehnt mit
putin darüber zu reden also das muss man
auch sehen das rechtfertigt den krieg
nicht also und ich dass ich jetzt hier
wieder in der weise interpretiert werde
durch ist der krieg trotzdem ein
verbrechen aber ich glaube dass man ihn
vielleicht hätte verhindern können durch
solche gespräche beiden hat sie nicht
gehörte aber jetzt haben wir die
situation so wie sie jetzt ist es bringt
ja nichts
entgegensetzen da würde ich aber auch
sagen dann würde es ja nur was bringen
also bin ich ihre argumentation folge
dass es nur hilfen würde wenn bei wenn
joe biden mit ihm sprechen hier sollten
auch beide so druck setzen ja also
deswegen weswegen man sich im vorfeld
sind ja gespräche glaube das hat eher zu
nichts geführt sw also wissen warum das
ist ja schon eine sehr wichtige frage
warum ist für beide nicht hin geflogen
er wollte sich nicht zu der familien
lassen da an diesen langen tisch zu
sitzen wo puten dann hoch hält ok jetzt
beiden hat mit ihm gesprochen und das
fehlen der gerade weil ich versucht in
einem anderen land zu treffen wie zum
beispiel also man hat schon mehrmals
getroffen aber das hat es nicht mehr
also leute denken mit genug gespräche
können wir die probleme lösen es tut mir
leid ja aber man kann bis ende der tage
darüber sprechen putin wollte angreifen
tobt und die gespräche haben ihnen nicht
davon abgehalten und es ist auch so dass
fehlende verhandlungen und
verhandlungsbereitschaft ihn nicht daran
hindern den frieden zu suchen man ist
bereit mit ihnen zu reden aber man will
nicht frieden um jeden preis und für die
ukraine geht es nicht um frieden sondern
um den see das heißt dass die besetzten
gebieten werden befreit und die
verhandlung die kommen können denke ich
werden nur da sein wenn putin bereit ist
den land zu räumen und ich kompromisse
das ist realistisch weil immerhin sie
haben gesagt dass die russen weiter
fortschritte machen aber die die die
weite spektrum der meinung sagt dass
erstens bei den lebensmittellieferung es
war die ukrainische marine und die
raketen die die russische marine
festgehalten haben und dass sie aus
legalen besetzt haben dass putin meinte
ich kann das militärisch nicht mehr
halten ich lasse das kommt mir einmal
zurück in deutschland bin und auch
gesagt habe wir müssen da jetzt stärke
zeigen es sind ja viele probleme da die
möglich sind wie zb auch mögliche
blackouts da würde ich gerne einmal reif
schuler frage nach der stimmung in
diesem land der stimmung in der politik
was man da eigentlich erwartet für den
winter man erwartet ganz klar die einen
sagen so offen die anderen drücken sie
noch ein bisschen rum man erwartet eine
rezession also ein wirkliches absinken
der wirtschaftskraft die definition ist
wenn zwei quartale hintereinander ein
negativer
wirtschaftswachstum also ein minus beim
wirtschaften
zu verzeichnen ist dass das noch in der
rezession ist das dürfte tiefer werden
also die berater auch im
finanzministerium gehen davon aus dass
das schon massiv werden wird der ifo
geschäftsklimaindex ist dafür ein ganz
guter
gutes anzeichen also man geht auch davon
aus dass beispielsweise es gibt sowieso
bestimmte so ein bisschen wie
wirtschafts mystik wenn beispielsweise
die grundstoff produktion für
produzierendes gewerbe also die die
basis materialien die man braucht und
die beimischung
advent wenn die weniger bestellt werden
da gehen die firmen offensichtlich davon
aus dass das alles sehr heikel wird und
dass man nicht weiß ob man das geschäft
aufrecht erhalten kann also die stimmung
ist mies und auch die politik hat hohe
angst davor dass diese miese stimmung
der wirtschaft sich in rezessionen
niederschlägt in hohe inflation in hohe
energiepreise die dann wiederum
umschlagen in eine wut stimmung im
herbst werden die entlastungs paket ist
aufhören können die entlassungs pakete
sind betreffen ja jetzt erst mal nur
mehr oder weniger treff genau
energie-preise es geht jetzt nicht darum
die die die kurzarbeiter regelung ist
schon verlängert sodass also wenn es
weitere insolvenzen geben kann man kann
da vielleicht einige auffangen es ist
aber eigentlich auch allen klar dass wir
nicht die dritte große krise in folge
jetzt mit milliardenpaketen zu schützen
können so dass es möglichst schmerzfrei
an der bevölkerung vorübergeht und das
ist die ganz große angst die die gesamte
bundesregierung beseelt und wo sie auch
noch keine wirkliche antwort darauf
gefunden haben dass ist in der tat alles
sehr sehr angespannt und die das erste
paket was jetzt gerade beschlossen
worden ist ist ja erst mal nur formal
beschlossen und noch gar nicht in kraft
also da es hat noch kein rentner seine
300 euro bekommen
die studenten auch noch nicht und es
ist auch nicht ganz klar warum bei
riesen rentenerhöhungen diese in der
zeit gegeben hat man jetzt so tut als
seien die rentner vergessen worden die
sind nicht vergessen worden die haben
bewusst ausgeklammert was auch wieder
ungerecht ist weil es eben sehr niedrige
renten gibt und dann gibt es ganz gut
gestaltete pensionen die es nicht
wirklich nötig hätten das kann man aber
so nicht freuen das ist eine sehr
komplizierte geschichte das wirklich zu
puffern man nennt
dies plant prinzip und intern ist
natürlich auch klar dass wenn es
wirklich zu einer harten rezession
kommen sollte dass dann die
schuldenbremse im nächsten jahr nicht
eingehalten wird aber das ist immer so
ein spiel in der politik man muss immer
erst die schmerzgrenze
spüren und dann kann man ja sagen ja
unter diesen bedingungen ich habe zwar
immer gesagt keine schuldenbremse aber
dann müssen wir es jetzt machen was
sollst du frau einzige echte ruhen uns
denn soziale unruhen ich glaube dass die
menschen protestieren müssen ich meine
was ich vorhin gesagt habe dass in
frankreich der sprit viel billiger ist
dass der strom viel billiger ist auch
gedeckelt ist das hat ja was damit zu
tun dass der makro angst hat vor
protesten also vor allem wieder
aufflammen dieser gelb westen bewegung
und das hat dann immerhin zur folge dass
die regierung ein bisschen mehr sozial
macht
das brauchen wir in deutschland auch
wobei ich mir keine illusionen mache ich
meine der großhandelspreis für gas hat
sich verzehnfacht also selbst also wenn
man die sanktionen aufrecht erhält
könnte also die wohlwollens der
regierung diese riesige differenz ja
nicht abfedern also das sind ja das ist
ja zwangsläufig immer nur tropfen auf
den heißen stein weil der staat hat ja
auch kein geld hier sind bordprogramm
wenn sie jetzt den sahra wagenknecht
drei-punkte-plan hätten also ich finde
tatsächlich wir müssen verhandeln über
eine wiederaufnahme der gaslieferung wir
haben keine andere chance es geht uns
die industrie kaputt und was weg ist ist
weg also das ja auch so wenn der habe
ich so sagt ja dagegen paar kaputt aber
die kommen ja vielleicht wieder man
hatte auch letztens das handelsblatt
noch mal ganz klar analysiert zb
unternehmen die jetzt verlagert werden
die kommen nicht zurück bedingung
sozusagen
wiederaufnahme der verhandlung welche
konzession würden sie putin waren so
dass er wieder gas fließen lässt ja
erstmal müsste man hören also ich glaube
dass aber das ist mein glauben das muss
man halt verhandeln wenn wir dort sind
zwei öffnen würden das wahrscheinlich
fließen würde aber weiß ich nicht muss
auch die nächste turbine ja wieder
kaputt dass ich meine das interesse soll
denn putin daran haben dass er jetzt
wieder liefert die märkte nehmen das als
signal entspannung der preis geht wieder
runter jetzt kann putin sehr viel
weniger liefern und nicht mehr geld ein
ideal warum sollte er das öffnen nur
damit ball geht neben trotzdem zwei
natürlich für russland sondern art
prestige projekt ist ich weiß es nicht
aber wir müssen noch versuchen kann auch
sein dass er sagt ja gut das machen wir
aber nur werde die enteignung unser
zentralbankreserven rückgängig macht
oder wenn wir unsere banken weder beim
stift dabei sind aber wir müssen noch
einfach sehen das gesamte sanktionspaket
und wie er das auch die unehrlichkeit
oder 1 sind ja wie gesagt sieben große
sanktionspaket die eu gemacht hat so
haben wir noch nie auf einen krieg
reagiert und die welt ist voll von
völkerrechtswidrigen schlimmen kriegen
also ganz angefangen von den usa den
nächsten jahren soll amerika ist alles
wieder wie
gesagt also wir müssen ja gar nicht mehr
können unseren nato verbündeten türkei
nehmen die besetzen auch aktuell
völkerrechtswidrig in nordsyrien und
daher weise im irak gebiete die haben
ich würde sagen oder ich kann also kein
tugend ok angst ist kein typen
deutschland hat die berliner blockade
überstanden deutschland selbst
deutschland hat opec öl embargo
überstanden deutschland wird das auch
überstehen wenn die deutschen verstehen
was auf dem spiel steht wenn man nur
sagt es ist irgendeine
abgefahrene willkürliche politik den
russen den geld nicht mehr zu schicken
natürlich werden die deutschen dann
damit kommen aber wenn wir uns sagt was
ein beitrag die machen für die ukraine
was sein beitrag sie zur europäischen
frieden machen dass keiner denkt daran
einfach so länder angreifen wenn sie die
deutschen das sagen
dann werden die auch ein bisschen opfern
und ich bin auch überzeugt dass diese
verzehnfachung der gaspreise in eine
sehr liquide gasmarkt auch nicht das
ende der geschichte ist sondern
alternativen werden kommen ja wo sollen
die denn herkommen die am lmg taxis aus
usa den neuen rosinenbomber wenn sie
als preis also ich meine das ist doch
klar
also das sind ja ich meine wir haben
hier sogar relativ volle da speichert
abrüstet nur über die regierung aber da
ist genau dieses teure gas tritt also
aktuell läuft es doch so die regierung
hat ja ein riesen kredit gegeben dafür
dass man jetzt am weltmarkt zu jedem
beliebigen preis gas kauft ja dadurch
treiben wir selber dem preis mit hoch
muss man auch wissen wir ruinieren auch
andere länder mit die nämlich also
gerade ärmere länder die können kein gas
mehr kaufen weil wir die preise
hochtreiben aber nicht nur das sondern
dieses teure gas was jetzt in den
speichern es wird ja irgendwann
verbraucht von den familien von den
unternehmen und da und die müssen dann
diese ehrenpreise bezahlt wer 10 also
viel wie in der vergangenheit das ist
aber
welche kapazitäten gerade in amerika die
man vor 20 jahren hat keine gedacht
amerika kommt von steinkohle weg heute
sind die co2 emissionen von amerika auf
den punkt von 1990 obwohl der wirtschaft
drei prozent pro jahr wächst wegen diese
schiefergas und
jan an schiefergas ist nicht so
schädlich wie eine offene tages mine
hier im jüdisch und sowas wenn man an
wasser denkt schiefergas
behauptet aber es ist schwierig aber
weltweit immer paket gut war morgens
auch denken der vergangenheit vor zwei
jahren war so gering dass leute bezahlt
haben dass leute ihr öl lagern und jetzt
ist der preis sehr hoch aber diese preis
ist ja elastisch das heißt die anbieter
werden dann die zapfen wieder andrehen
und die pipelines im gange stern zb ein
lng produzent
werden sie noch einmal einladen
sich vorstellen eine kurze unterbrechung
und dann warten zwei weitere spannende
thema auf 7
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter brauchen
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 485 köpfen fünf meinungen von
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt ärgert freut oder
schockiert
so nicht
herr jörges will wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen hier einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland wie ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dürfte sein dass im gehirn eines konnte
zum manko leicht einmal kurz
doch das ist übliche an dem radträger
ausdrücken ich habe mein beifahrer eine
sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand ist war die heldin anderer
name ist er ganz klar ist auch darüber
sprechen dass ein tag nicht fertig
richtig wo ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und kommen direkt zu der
these von ralf schuler
ich habe dieser tage ein foto gesehen
von
grh insel backe oliver pocher der war in
katar und hat sich dort mit einer
deutschlandfahne und einer ein bisschen
kleinen regenbogen armbinde ablichten
lassen ja toll ein ganz mutig also
peinlicher gratis mit peinlicher geht's
eigentlich schon nicht mehr
man muss sich einfach klarmachen dieses
land hat gastarbeiter die unter klaren
bedingungen gehalten werden müssen ihre
pässe abgeben es gibt ein cover system
wo der wo der arbeitgeber entscheiden
kann wie lange erarbeitet werden
schlecht bezahlt
6500 bis 15.000 plugin schätzungen
auseinander sind gestorben weil die
bedingungen so so schlimm sind es gibt
keine pressefreiheit es gibt ein äußerst
orthodoxen islam religionsfreiheit ist
ein fremdwort es gibt strafen von
auspeitschen bis erschießen es gibt
natürlich keine keine meinungsfreiheit
sondern es herrscht in feudaler manier
eine eine
sultanats regierung die auch nicht
abwählbar ist frauenrechte sind im
prinzip ein fremdwort frauen müssen von
ihren männern unterschrieben bekommen
wenn sie auslandsstipendien antreten
wollen wenn sie verträge schließen da
ist dass das mittelalter noch
eine feine sache dagegen man kann
verurteilt werden wegen ungehorsams
wegen ehebruch wegen alkoholkonsum in
der öffentlichkeit als muslim wir haben
ein düsteres unrechtsregime hinter
zugegebenermaßen glänzenden fassaden und
dann stellt sich herr pocher hin und
feiert sich für den mut dort ein
regenbogen binde getragen zu haben
dieses land geht unter der knute und da
wir übertragen dann einfach unsere
konflikte dahin es geht nicht um ein
paar lesben schwulen oder oder
transsexuelle es geht darum dass ein
ganzes regime dort wirklich
menschenrechte mit füßen tritt und das
ist einfach eine verniedlichung wenn man
sich solche späßchen erlaubt und ich
kann einfach nur sagen augen auf münder
auf das ganze ansprechen und nicht
solche scherz aktionen und so tun als
wäre man jetzt der mut bolzen der nation
frau körpern blick auf die fußball wm
sollte die regierung auf eine teilnahme
verzichten ja absolut also ich glaube
das kann man auch niemandem erklären
wenn die regierung dort vor ort ist bei
den menschenrechtsverletzungen die dort
stattfinden und ich habe es ja gerade
erwähnt wie mit frauen vor allem dort
umgegangen wird ich glaube wir würden
uns viel viel mehr schaden und ich weiß
nicht wer spaß daran hat da hinzufliegen
sich das da vor ort anzuschauen weil man
weiß wie eigentlich dort die lage vor
ort ist der wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck hat ja auch mit katar verhandelt
wir erinnern uns alle an die fotos dahin
stand natürlich schon der eindruck dass
deutschland und katar jetzt auf dem weg
sind ziemlich beste freunde zu werden
das glaube ich gar nicht hat ja auch
gesagt er macht das also
interview daher auch gesagt dass er es
auch nicht findet dass er jetzt eine
ganz einfach in der videobotschaft kind
haben eine andere sprache gesprochen und
es hat übrigens nichts gebracht also
nicht auf einen cent höher genannt jahre
gekommen und leben retten waren die
bilder nicht fast schlimmer als signal
für die welt als wenn er jetzt dahin
fliegen würde zu fußballspielen nein das
glaube ich nicht weil man zum
fußballspiel hinfliegt und sich dort
sage ich man seine freizeit irgendwie
bewegt uns spaß dort verortet ist was
anderes als wenn ich vor ort hingehe und
versuche für mein land etwas zu
erreichen also jetzt schon zwei unter
die geschäfte machen ja teilnahme
fußball-wm ganzen geschäfte machen ja
man hat der gesetzgeber gar kein
geschäft entstanden so und da sieht man
ja auch dass geschäfte ja wir machen ja
mit der ganzen region ein kater ist eine
islamistische diktatur kann man einfach
mal so mit diesem begriff umschreiben
und ich meine ich sagte ja gar nicht
dass wir jetzt nur mit lupenreinen
demokratien handel training dabei als
möglich aber das zeigt eben wieder mal
die völlig doppelten maßstäbe mit denen
wir agieren und ich fahren wirklich auch
damals also ich finde auch dieses
peinlich was sie angesprochen haben aber
ich fand wirklich diesen arbeitsbesuch
natürlich auch oberpeinlich also er ist
ja nicht nur hin gefahren sondern hat
auch noch einen bückling gemacht also
wirklich
und ich finde also natürlich finde ich
auch dass die bundesregierung nicht
hinfahren sollte aber es ist eben
einfach diese unehrlichkeit ich mein
katar ist ja nicht nur ein unterdrücker
systemen auch gegenüber frauen und und
opposition die haben auch jahrelang im
jemen mit saudi arabien zusammen den
krieg geführt als er kriegt läuft immer
noch katar macht zurzeit nicht mit aber
haben wir damals irgendwie gesagt so
jetzt müssen wir unsere wirtschaftlichen
verbindungen kappen jetzt müssen wir
unsere geschäfte beendet an wir haben ja
auch geschäfte mit saudi arabien die
immer noch dort bomben werfen also wie
gesagt das sind schlimme diktaturen die
wirklich auch für die menschen in diesen
ländern zumindest sofern sie ein
bisschen oppositionelle sind oder auch
nur weiblich oder homosexuell eine
katastrophe sind es sind länder diesen
außenpolitisch aggressiv sind auch für
kriegsverbrechen verantwortlich und
trotzdem macht man da business as usual
als sie würden sanktionen befürworten
würden irgendwie vorgehen ich glaube
nicht dass wir uns einen gefallen tun
wenn wir jedes land dessen beschrieben
wir ablehnen und zwar aus guten gründen
mit sanktionen belegt ich meine mit wem
machen wir da noch handelt aber in der
eu hat sie sind damit einverstanden dass
man mit saudi arabien und katar handelt
wenn es notwendig ist ich finde dass wir
klar ansprechen müssen wie unsere
haltung zu den regimen ist aber wir
haben geschäftsbeziehungen man muss
gucken wenn man die wenn man bessere
möglichkeiten hat immer aber wir können
jetzt nicht jedes land mit sanktionen
belegen dass solche politischen system
hat also das geht also ich meine
das nicht daran stört ist dass solche
aktionen einfach das problem
verniedlichen in dem man so tut ich habe
ja eine binde ich mal kurz es steht
deutschland hinter oliver pocher die
hauen ihnen immer raus wenn er wirklich
festgenommen werden sollte vor der wm
wird auch katar kein interesse daran
haben ihnen irgendwie einzusperren oder
große wellen zu schlagen also das ist
echt gratis mut von der kleinsten münze
und sowas bringt niemanden weiter und
sowas kann man sich sparen dann soll er
einfach mal ein ernsthaftes gespräch mit
ein paar unterdrückten frauen führen die
da im knast sitzen da sind etliche
journalistinnen eingesperrt da hätte er
mehr und vielleicht auch ohne
öffentlichkeit da hat er mir hätte er
mehr bewirkt als mit solchen spaß
aktionen nach dem thema nacktheit und
auch kommunikation also jetzt heuchelei
war sehr darüber haben wir jetzt aber
das thema sauberkeit und das von ihnen
frauen mitgebracht bekommen ja genau ich
hatte schon der windkraft als
bürgermeister werde ich immer wieder
angesprochen dass man die politik die
gerade ist dass man das nicht versteht
dass
viel gesprochen wird aber nicht an kommt
bei den menschen und da fragt man sich
schon wie weit entfernt hat sich denn
die politik von den menschen und ich bin
mir sicher dass auch jetzt mit dem
dritten entlastungspaket alle wollen das
beste für den menschen aber vergessen
dabei dass so kommunikativ
rüberzubringen dass es verstehen was da
eigentlich passiert und so verlieren wir
die menschen und da sollten wir fall
aufpassen dass ich einfach direkt und
schnell und kommunikativ sind frau
wagenknecht wie sehr verlieren wieder in
die menschen was merken wir dann auch
weil sich wenn sie mit den bürgern
sprechen sie bekommen ja auch viele
zuschriften ja ich will kommen sehr viel
und ich glaube es ist nicht nur ein
kommunikationsproblem also auch klar
politik bewegt sich oft in der blase
wenn man nicht aktiv etwas dagegen tut
weil ein politiker ist natürlich
privilegiert er lebt in einer anderen
welt und wenn menschen das spüren also
wenn zum beispiel mal eben so getan wird
ja also wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen
uns also unser wohlstand etwas
reduzieren na klar also für minister
auch wenn abgeordnete kann seinen
wohlstand reduzieren aber doch nicht
jemand eine alleinerziehende mutter die
so schon nicht überboten monat kommt
oder eine rentnerin mit einer niedrigen
rente oder auch ein familienvater der
jeden abend viel zu spät nach hause
kommt und kaum zeit für seine familie
hat damit irgendwie die ernähren kann
also die können nicht in wohlstand
reduzieren weil sie schon nur ein
gescheiter gaben politiker jemals näher
bei den leuten
ich würde schon sagen dass ich da in der
bundesrepublik was verändert hat ja also
wir sehen es ja auch daran es war ja mal
eine viel höhere wahlbeteiligung als die
leute haben ja auch das gefühl gehabt
offenbar dass sie mehr verstanden werden
und wir haben schon eine immer stärkere
einflussnahme auch große unternehmen auf
die politik nicht der kleine nicht des
mittelstands aber großer konzerne mit
ihren lobbyisten die immer stärker auch
die gesetze machen wir hatten das vor
der finanzkrise als schwuler steigt die
einflussnahme der unternehmen die these
von frau wagenknecht
das ist schwer zu messen ob das dann
steigt oder ob aufs feld die der
einfluss war immer da man kann ja nicht
als eine der größten wirtschaftsnationen
der welt eine politik machen die quasi
an der wirtschaft vorbei geht um die
großen und daneben es geht nicht um die
in die mittleren und ja aber anja engel
die aber deutschland hat ja immer
politik im sinne der autoindustrie
beispielsweise gemacht oder des
maschinenbaus die interessen zu
vertreten ist ja legitim die frage ist
ob illegitim einfluss genommen wird
zugunsten einer branche die dann sich
vorteile verschafft oder im
internationalen wettbewerb wenn man sich
anguckt was die franzosen innerhalb der
europäischen union mit ihrer agrar
sparte machen das ist auch nicht ganz
sauber und ordnungspolitisch auch nicht
ganz in ordnung also ist soweit okay wie
wir interessen unseres landes vertreten
und nicht monopole schaffen nicht
einzelnen leuten irgendwas zuschuss dann
das ist schon völlig in ordnung das
andere problem was wir in der tat haben
ist dass die kommunikationswege so viel
vielfältiger geworden sind heutzutage
dass auch politiker einfach mehr arbeit
bei der kommunikation zukommt und das
haben viele nicht begriffen ich krieg
aus der unionsfraktion täglich ein
mehrere dutzend pressemitteilung die
fleißige hände dort tapfer jeden tag
verschicken die
in 90 prozent der redaktionen sofort
gelöscht werden weil seine e mail fächer
verstopfen kein mensch druck
pressemitteilung ab das ist das hat mit
kommunikation nichts zu tun und
rausgehen meinetwegen können die sich
sparen das können sie sich sparen das
ist aber vielleicht auch ein
arbeitsnachweis für einzelne abgeordnete
die sprecher einer ag sind oder was das
kapitel ist schade am ende auch nichts
das problem ist einfach dass viele
politiker noch nicht verstanden haben
dass kommunikation zu einer dauer
angelegenheit geworden ist und nicht nur
alle vier jahre mal den schirm vom
supermarkt aufstellen oder auf dem
offenen markt man sollte schon öfter da
sein weil sonst einfach die
kommunikations möglichkeiten so
vielfältig sind dass die leute sich dann
im netz informieren ganze milieus sich
das zusammenballen und sich die
informationen suchen die ihre ideen am
besten bestätigen und die sind auch dann
später nicht mehr rückholbar also man
muss eigentlich versuchen ständig
erreichbar zu sein ständig zu
kommunizieren gern auch auf sozialen
medien das ist verdammt anstrengend
einem ruinierten mitunter auch die
nerven man kriegt ja nicht nur zuspruch
aber anders funktioniert es nicht wenn
die leute nicht das gefühl geben was
ist denn eigentlich noch möglich als
bürgermeister ist jetzt nicht ganz so
groß wie man sich das ja so heißt es
denn da für sie noch möglich was
eigentlich reif schüler gerade gefordert
hat dass man wirklich da ist nicht alles
beantworten ich finde das kann man
fordern also ich sehe es beim einen
bundestagsabgeordneten es ist sehr wohl
möglich der ist im sommer sechs sieben
acht wochen unterwegs lars klingbeil
recht ist was klingt wie ein und chefin
von laska aber ist eine kreisvorsitzende
will ja aber ich meine das jetzt im
ernst der ist unser motto jedes er
glaubt er macht schon seit 10 der ist da
und jeden tag gibt es eine runde wo
leute dazukommen können und zusätzlich
dazu gibt es eine telefonsprechstunde
die zeit nimmt er sich und er ist
parteivorsitzender und
bundestagsabgeordneter das erwarte ich
auch irgendwie und das kann ich auch von
anderen abgeordneten erwarten und das
sehe ich leider nicht weil einen
abgeordneten die sich hier vermutlich
jetzt auch bei der spd und insbesondere
bei last klingen bei großen redebedarf
wenn er durch vor allem auch spd wähler
würde ich jetzt mal schätzen natürlich
auch angst haben mit blick auf den
winter absolut natürlich haben sie angst
und das merke ich halte meinen
sprechstunden auch dass die menschen
kommen und sagen wie ist denn das jetzt
mit dieser energiekosten den rentner
hatten warum kriegen wir denn eigentlich
nicht studieren die mir schreiben über
instagram und sagen was warum wollen wir
den verkehr sondern müssen wie das
erklären und es wäre einfacher wenn sich
die abgeordnete ja auch im bundestag
sitzen diese politik mittragen vor ort
gehen für die kommunen reingehen und
ihre politik erkläre was sagen sie denn
dann wenn jemand sagt so warum wurde ich
denn jetzt vergesst nicht meint olaf
scholz ist ja ihr spd boss kann man
jetzt war salopp sagen was sagen na ja
also ich brauch nicht alles schön zu
reden das ist einfach so gerade bei den
rentnern studierenden so mein kleiner
bruder selber studieren da sagte ich ich
erlebt dass ja hautnah da ich auch ich
kann das nicht verstehen ich verstehe es
nicht so hätte ich jetzt kann man sagen
ja ich weiß ja nicht ob christian
lindner das geld nicht ausgeben wollte
keine ahnung aber dafür setzt sich auch
nicht in berlin aber bei solchen sachen
muss man ehrlich sein und wenn ich der
meinung bin ich verstehe es auch nicht
ich habe dafür kein verständnis warum
rentnerin dann nicht dieser die
kostenpauschale bekommen sollte nur noch
studieren dann sage ich das auch ehrlich
und dann ist mir das eigentlich auch
egal dass olaf scholz spd kanzler ist
aber da muss man ehrlich sein und so
kann man die leute auch nicht alles
merken sie ja auch so dass heißt der
bundestag muss mehr arbeiten zumindest
müssen sie vor ort ihre leute mitnehmen
können und wenn wir das nicht machen
verlieren wir sie einfach und wir haben
halt so eine krisenzeit gerade und das
50 niemand und ich merke ja auch die
leute die die laufen und die wollen das
beste für den für die bürgerinnen bürger
aber es muss verständlich erklärt werden
und es muss vor ort rübergebracht werden
vorrangig dass ich wahrscheinlich
dieselbe meinung ja also ich finde das
absolut richtig die forderung dass
politiker wirklich mit den bürgern reden
dass sie vor ort sind dass sie auch
veranstaltungen machen ich meine das ist
für mich auch ein lebenselixier also
diese direkte kommunikation natürlich
auch über social media klar man kriegt
ja auch ganz viele reaktionen bei
youtube bei instagram bei facebook alles
wichtig auch dass sie nicht nur in ihrer
babbel sind also das ist auch eine
gefahr also das sehe ich durchaus bei
politikern also die jetzt vor allem in
social media unterwegs sind da muss man
natürlich aufpassen man hat natürlich
meistens eine bestimmte blase und wenn
man zum beispiel twitter das was da
andere aktion kommt für die welt hält
dann kann da eine ziemlich schräge
politik raus kommen aber ich würde
trotzdem noch mal an meinem ursprungs
these anknüpfen also dass die politiker
vor ort sind dass sie mit den menschen
reden dass sie deren probleme überhaupt
kennen und wahrnehmen und wissen und
nicht irgendwie so daher reden alles
wichtig alles richtig aber eine gute
politik muss gut erklärt werden aber
eine schlechte politik da nützt es dann
auch nicht sie vor ort gut zu erklären
weil die leute trotzdem merken mir geht
es schlechter ich werde hier überzogen
ich verliere wohlstand oder ich habe
kaum ein und jetzt werde ich richtig arm
gemacht also das ist schon ein problem
und wenn sie sagen die politik ist nicht
mehr abgehoben als früher ja zum
beispiel die verflechtungen mit der
wirtschaft die haben ja deutlich
zugenommen also diese drehtüreffekt nur
politiker macht einem unternehmen einen
großen gefallen und wenn er dann nicht
mehr aktiver politiker ist dann wechselt
er in genau das unternehmen das er
vorher begünstigt hat das gab es früher
in dieser form nicht darüber wie und
zumindest besprechen wenn sie das
nächste mal zu gast bei uns sind die
hunde hat sehr viel spaß weil ich auf
jeden auch schönen abend noch weil wir
sind jetzt am ende angekommen bis morgen
abend
[Musik]